today we're dropping a big bomb into the
deepest part of the ocean
so grab a surfboard and get ready to
hang 10
on the waves of a massive nuclear
tsunami
how would you deliver a nuke to the
bottom of the mariana trench
what would this underwater explosion be
like
and
what kind of destruction would it cause
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we nuked the mariana trench
welcome to the deepest
darkest depths of the ocean
the mariana trench is located in the
western pacific ocean
just 360 kilometers away from the island
of guam
you'll be traveling down 11 kilometers
to challenger deep the deepest point of
the trench
here you could stack about 30 empire
state buildings on top of each other
before hitting the surface
you'd be among the brave few to venture
into these high pressure pitch black and
near freezing waters
joining the company of scientists a
naval officer and even filmmaker james
cameron
but you'll be carrying the most precious
cargo of all
the biggest nuclear bomb ever made
[Music]
back on land your most precious cargo
lies in the device you're using to watch
me your data and if you want to protect
yourself on land
c or air you need bitdefender
i spend most of my days online and in
meetings in this remote environment but
with bitdefender i know that my camera
and my microphone stay secure and aren't
transmitted to someone else's laptop no
stranger to cyber security and highly
rated by independent labs bitdefender is
the award-winning leader delivering
first-class threat prevention detection
and response solutions
windows mac os ios or android you're
covered by tools so advanced they stop
attacks before they even begin
click on the link in the description
below and get an extended trial for
bitdefender total security on up to five
devices that's 120 days of total
security and peace of mind
if you don't keep your data safe you may
have to dump your hard drive at the
bottom of this trench
okay wait before you worry about what
would happen if you exploded a bomb at
the bottom of the trench
you'd want to figure out how to get it
there safely
if a bomb accidentally exploded near the
surface
it could be dangerous for
many people
you could think of it as a massive
nuclear tsunami
waves hundreds of meters high spreading
out in all directions
this could create a hazardous situation
for the islands neighboring the mariana
trench
like guam japan or the philippines
luckily these waves would behave
differently than your regular tsunami
waves
they would break earlier
that means they'd be smaller and less
catastrophic when they reached land
but still better to avoid this crisis
and get that bomb safely down into the
trench
to do this you'd have to protect it from
extremely high pressures
at the bottom of the trench the pressure
is so high it would be like having 100
adult elephants on your head
you'd want to use a special pressure
vessel to transport the bomb
just like operation wigwam
in 1955 the united states detonated a
bomb at a depth of 600 meters
it was twice as powerful as the bomb
dropped on hiroshima
the explosion generated a massive bubble
across the water and deadly radioactive
contamination spread across 13 square
kilometers
but your bomb would be the largest nuke
ever created
more like the tsar bomba
this nuclear weapon was over 3 000 times
more powerful than little boy the bomb
dropped on nagasaki
and you'd have to take it much
much deeper than the wigwam test
at the moment of detonation a bubble of
hot steam would expand rapidly
in just a few seconds it would cover an
area of about one kilometer
on the surface you'd see a massive bulge
in the water
but it wouldn't reach great heights
that's because you would detonate the
bomb so deep that the water pressure
above would cause the bubble to collapse
but within a few seconds that bubble
would shrink then start to expand
outward again
this expansion and contraction would
continue for three or four cycles
this would leave the water turbulent hot
and
mixed with radioactive debris
at least no neighboring coastal cities
would have to worry about being wiped
out by a tsunami
but you certainly wouldn't see the
effects ending there
the increased temperatures from the
explosion could create intense
hurricanes
and the turbulent waters and radioactive
material would have adverse effects on
marine life
there would be mass casualties from the
explosion
and deep sea fish could be blinded by
the bright flash of light
over time you could see unexpected or
surprising effects on the ecosystem near
the detonation site
there are corals as big as cars after
the 23 detonations at the u.s nuclear
testing site on bikini atoll
not to mention an abundance of aquatic
animal life
but you could see mutations of marine
life after a while
maybe this could create a real-life
godzilla monster
[Music]
but that sounds like a story
for another what if